we can calculate candlest Tau with this
formula where C is the number of
concordant pairs and D is the number of
discordant pairs what are concordant and
discordant pairs we will now go through
this with a simple example suppose two
doctors are asked to rank six patients
according to their physical health one
of the doctors is now defined as a
reference and the patients are sorted
from 1 to 6. now the sorted ranks are
matched with the ranks of the other
doctor EG the patient who is in third
place with a reference Doctor Is In
fourth place with the other doctor now
using candlest Tau we want to know if
there is a correlation between the two
ratings for the correlation of candles
Tau we only need these ranks we now look
at each individual Rank and note whether
the values below are smaller or greater
than itself so we start at the first
rank 3